I've been doing a bunch of videos about
logarithmic scale and we've also
unfortunately had many notable
earthquakes this year so I thought I
would do a video on the Richter scale
which is a way to measure which is a way
to measure earthquake magnitudes and
just to be clear although we associate
the Richter scale as the way we measure
earthquakes now the one that we actually
use now is the moment magnitude scale
and the reason why most people don't
make a huge differentiation between the
two is that the moment magnitude scale
was calibrated to the Richter scale but
the whole reason why we moved to the
moment magnitude scale is that the
Richter scale starts to kind of max out
at around magnitude 7 earthquakes so
this gives us a much better way to
measure things that are above a
magnitude 7 so this right here is a
picture of Charles Richter he's passed
away but this is from an interview that
he gave and it's interesting because it
kind of gives the rationale for how he
came up with the Richter scale
I found a paper by Professor K wa da T
of Japan in which he compared large
earthquakes by plotting the maximum
ground motion against the distance to
the epicenter so this professor kala
Dottie would you could imagine he did a
plot like this where this is distance
distance so if you have an earthquake
someplace you aren't always sitting
right on top of the epicenter where you
measure it you might be sitting over
here you're actually measure state
you're measuring stations might be some
distance away so he looks at how far the
measuring station was and then he looks
at the ground motion at the measuring
station so that he would that would be
some earthquake over there
relatively let's say that's a relatively
medium earthquake this right over here
would be a weak earthquake because
you're close to the earthquake and it
still didn't move the ground much so I
mean this is the magnitude this axis is
the magnitude how much the ground is
moving and then for example this would
be a very strong earthquake and then
Charles Richter said in the interview I
tried a similar procedure for our
stations but the range between the
largest and smallest magnitudes seemed
unmanageably large so what he's saying
is when he tried to plot it like
professor hua Dottie he found that okay
you could put you get some earthquakes
that you could plot around here but no
matter how you create a linear scale no
matter how you do a linear scale over
here
if you want any resolution down here the
stronger earthquakes just go off the
charts or maybe off the page so the
stronger earthquakes you might have to
start plotting here or here or maybe
they don't even fit on the page and so
he says dr. Beno Gutenberg and they were
all working at Cal Tech when they came
up with the Richter scale
dr. Beno Gutenberg then made the natural
suggestion to plot the amplitudes
logarithmic ly I was I was lucky because
logarithmic plots are a device of the
devil and I'm not really sure what he
means when he says that they were a
device of the devil I'm assuming he
means that they're kind of magical that
all of a sudden you could take these
things that you want your resolution
down here you want to be able to tell
the difference between those we cue
earthquakes but at the same time you
want to be able to compare them to the
large earthquakes and he thought I guess
he viewed them as a bit of a magical
instrument and we say that they're
logarithmic or he plotted on a
logarithmic scale what essentially is
he's saying is he's essentially taking
the logarithm of the magnitude of every
one of those earthquakes so if you're
measuring the earthquake maybe on a
seismograph so this is before they'll
quickly and the earthquake hits and then
the earthquake stops and then you
measure the amplitude of this earthquake
if you just plotted them linearly you
would have the problem that he saw or if
you tried to plot him the way doc
professor what daddy did it you would
have that problem but what he does is he
measures this now and he plots the
logarithm the logarithm of that and so
what happens is that you get a scale
that is plotted or you get a logarithmic
scale for lack of a better word but what
I want to do in this video is think
about how what implication that has for
the magnitude of earthquakes especially
some of the earthquakes that we have
seen recently so this right here is the
earthquake that occurred August 23rd on
the East Coast United States and it
wasn't that strong of an earthquake it
was a 5.8 that's not a small earthquake
you would definitely feel it's a good
bit of shaking it can even cause some
minor damage but the reason why it's
notable is it happened in a part of the
world that does not see earthquakes too
frequently so let's just protect that on
our scale I'm gonna go down all the way
over here so I'm gonna do our scale here
so this is let's just put that as a 5.8
and if you shake your seat fairly fairly
vigorously that'll give you a good idea
of what it might feel like on the top of
that earthquake
so this is 2011 East Coast earthquake
East Coast earthquake and then probably
the most famous earthquake in the United
States in recent memory was the one that
occurred at Loma Prieta this is Loma
Prieta right over here about 40 or 50
miles south of San Francisco and this is
damage that was caused in San Francisco
an actual freeway collapsed right over
here and this whole areas actually now
become very nice after they removed this
freeway but you could imagine how
powerful it was that it was able to
cause this type of damage this far away
and actually I live I live right over
here so I'm glad I wasn't around when I
wasn't in the Bay Area during that
earthquake but that earthquake they're
depending on you measured but we'll just
call it a 7.0 so that earthquake
measured at a 7.0 so let's call this so
this right over here is seven let me do
the color you're more likely to see so
that earthquake was a 7.0 Loma Prieta
Loma Prieta that was in the San
Francisco Bay Area and this was in 1989
it happened right actually before the
World Series and then of course 2011 a
very unfortunate earthquake in Japan the
Tohoku earthquake right over here this
circle shows the magnitude of that
earthquake it was off the coast of Japan
all of these were the aftershocks and
the real damage it caused was really the
tsunami and the damage it did to the
Fukushima nuclear power plant but that
was an 8-point well sometimes it's
called 8.9 sometimes a 9.0 depending on
how you measure it let's just call that
a 9.0 for simplicity so this let's say
this is almost 6 and this would be 7
then an 8 would get us right over there
so a 9.0 was right over there so this is
2011 the earthquake in Japan the Tohoku
earthquake and then the largest
earthquake ever recorded was the great
Chilean earthquake in 1960 and that was
a 9.5 so a 9.5 would stick us right over
let's say right over the year and this
is the 1960 quake in Chile and just to
give a sense you know when you look at
this well if you thought that this was a
linear scale you'd say okay the Chilean
earthquake maybe that was a little bit a
little bit less than twice as bad as the
East Coast earthquake and it doesn't
too bad until you realize that it is not
a linear scale it is a logarithmic scale
and the way that you interpret it the
way that you interpret it is it's
thinking about how many powers of 10 one
of these earthquakes is from another so
you can view these as powers of 10 so if
you take go from 5.8 to 7.0 that was one
point to a 1.0 1.2 difference but
remember this is a logarithmic scale and
I encourage you to watch the videos we
made on the logarithmic scale on a
logarithmic scale a fixed distance is
not a fixed amount of movement on that
scale or a change on that scale it's not
kind of a fixed a fixed linear distance
it is actually a scaling factor and
you're not scaling by 1.2 over here
you're scaling by 10 to the 1.2 power so
this is times 10 to the 1.2 power so
I'll get my calculator out right over
here let's figure out what that is so
you could imagine what it's going to be
10 to the first power is 10 and then you
have point to 2 so it's gonna be it's
gonna be let's just do it
10 10 to the 1.2 power
it's 15 point eight so it's roughly 16
times stronger so whatever shaking that
was just felt on the East Coast and
maybe some of y'all watching this might
be might have felt it Loma Prieta
earthquake was 16 times stronger than
the earthquake then the so let me write
this is 16 times stronger stronger than
the one that we just had in the East
Coast so that's a dramatic difference
even though this caused some damage and
this is kind of shaking this is shaking
on you know on a pretty good scale
imagine 16 times as much shaking and how
much damage that would cause I actually
just met a reporter who told me that you
know she was in her backyard during the
Loma Prieta earthquake not too far from
where I live now and she says all the
cars were like jumping up and down so it
was a massive massive earthquake now
let's think about the Japanese
earthquake we could think about how much
stronger was that a louver Prieta so
remember this isn't you don't just think
of this as oh it's just you know this is
this isn't just 2 times stronger it is
10 to the second time stronger and we
know how to figure that out 10 to the
second power is a hundred so this right
over here so cars were jumping up and
down at the Loma Prieta
earthquake the Japanese earthquake was
100 times stronger 100 times stronger
than Loma Prieta and if you compared to
the East Coast earthquake it would be
1,600 times 1,600 times the East Coast
the East Coast earthquake that occurred
in August of 2011 so massive massive
massive earthquake and just to get a
sense of how much stronger the Chilean
earthquake was in 1960 and just to and
there's some fascinating outcomes of the
Japanese earthquake it was estimated
that Japan over the course of the just
over the course of the earthquake got 13
feet wider so this is you know this is
happen this is doing something to the
actual shape of of a huge island and on
top of that it's estimated that that
because of the shaking and the
distortions in earth caused by that
shaking that the day on earth got one
millionth of a second shorter a little
over a millionth of a second shorter so
you might say hey that's only a
millionth of a second but I'd say hey
look it actually changed the the day of
the earth a very fundamental thing it
actually matters when people send things
into space and and and probes it to Mars
is that they are today able to know that
our day just got a millionth of a second
shorter so this was already a massive
quake and the Chilean earthquake is
going to be ten to the point five times
stronger than that so let's get our
calculator out
so you really could view this as a
square root of ten so ten to the point
five is the same thing as ten to the 1/2
which is the same thing as the square
root of ten which is three point one six
so the strongest earthquake on record
was three point one six times stronger
than the Japanese earthquake the one
that's shortened the day of the planet
the one that made the mage Japan 13 feet
wider and so this was if you wanted to
compare it if you want to compare it to
the East Coast earthquake this would be
almost or about five thousand times
stronger so massive massive earthquake
so one hopefully that gives you a sense
of of what the Richter scale is all
about it also gives you a sense of how
massive some of these super massive
earthquakes are and you can also
appreciate what Charles Richter's first
problem was if you wanted to plot all of
these on the same linear plot you would
have to stick this one you would have to
stick this one five thousand times
further along an axis than you would
have to stick this one and this one
itself is still a pretty big pretty big
earthquake so this would have to be five
thousand times further than some of the
earthquakes at the low end of the of the
Richter scale